here to
a port city in the deep south and if you
go down dauphin street mobile's old
immigrant and mercantile block where my
grandparents still have a store there
they've been long deceased and then
another family member runs it you'll see
stories that were run by lebanese cubans
greeks
poles
so i think that's the story that
gradually will get out to the rest of
the country and that is that the south
and the gulf coast in particular apart
from stories of race relations
hurricanes mardi gras baseball players
is one of tremendous
cultural diversity too much more subtle
than in the northeast but it's still
there only to be listened look at the
kids who've come through this wonderful
bus today
varying backgrounds different
nationalities this is
quietly diverse but it's there
roy hoffman author of back home journeys
through mobile thank you for your time
thank you
philosophy professor a.c grayling
examines the morality of allied air
attacks on civilians during world war ii
in his new book among the dead cities
next he's joined by christopher hitchens
author of love poverty and war to debate
whether the targeting of civilians can
be justified times of war this is two
hours
good evening
let's this work make sure they do good
evening ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the good institute washington the german
cultural center
i'm here about austrian the director of
the good institute washing
thank you for coming to this evening's
event
a special welcome to our guests ac
grayling
and christopher hitchens who will debate
professor grayling's new book among the
dead cities
and his deliberations on the moral
legacy of allied
area bombings in world war ii
why this debate in a german cultural
institute
i have to admit that i had doubts at
first
that this would be an appropriate venue
for this debate
and there were two reasons for my doubts
first in an emotional reaction
i felt shame
because you see
i think that a person or a group of
persons who committed atrocious crimes
and caused unimaginable suffering to so
many people
should not dwell on their own suffering
secondly
some people might misuse the arguments
and conclusions in professor grayling's
book
as he himself is very much aware of
and in this context some other people
might be suspicious
of our motivation for having this event
here
please let me
be very clear about this
nothing in professor grading's book can
change
the historical evaluation of at the
judgment on
what germany and germans did
during the third race
germany will have to live for a long
time with its past
however
never forgetting the history of the last
century we
and especially we at the good institute
are committed to work for a common
future
hoping
that certain things will never happen
again
to achieve this we want to learn from
the past and i hope tonight's debate
will be one opportunity to think about
what the moral questions raised in
professor grayling's book
mean for all of us today
i would like to thank walker and company
and the politics and prose bookstore
for suggesting this event and their
cooperation
in organizing it
thank you for your attention and now
please welcome george gibson with walker
and company
[Applause]
save it save it for them
my name is george gibson and i am the
publisher of walker and company a book
publisher in new york city and i also
want to start out by thanking harry
barrett and and the good institute and
the wonderful
local bookstore you have here in
washington dc politics and prose for
sponsoring and hosting this event
we had walker company have the honor
this month of publishing ac grayling's
new book among the dead cities
we have not and i should add at this
point to be fair to all of you but i
should add the word yet we have not yet
had the honor of ever publishing
christopher hitchens
but things in publishing are circular
and one never knows
[Laughter]
though i like you no doubt have had the
pleasure of reading him for many many
years
what distinguishes anthony grayling for
me anyway um is his desire um and
ability to make philosophy and the
the deep and often open-ended questions
it raises both accessible
to ordinary people and relevant to their
daily lives i don't know how this
evening is going to go
but i do know that at some point during
this conversation
the allied bombing of civilians in world
war ii more than 60 years ago is going
to be connected to our world today
anthony grayling is a professor of
philosophy at birkbeck college at the
university of london
he is the author of many other books
including a biography of the great
french mathematician and philosopher
rene descartes which walker will publish
this october
he is a fellow of the world economic
forum
and he contributes regularly to
a number of publications including the
economist the financial times um and the
observer
and he is also
a member of a regular panel on the bbc
world international um on on
international affairs
christopher hitchens i suspect needs
little introduction to the people in
this room
a prolific author journalist and critic
he is famously unafraid to have a strong
opinion and equally unafraid to change
that opinion over time
when we created a short list of people
we wanted to approach
to have a dialogue with anthony
he was at the very top of the list and
we're thrilled that he accepted
um you therefore have before you two of
the most um engaging
and uh and and interesting minds um in
the world today and i will now get out
of their way and let you hear them
but before i do let me just say they
will each speak for about 15 minutes
15-20 minutes
after which i'm sure they'll they'll
interact with each other and then we'll
take questions from the audience
after that books will be available
outside
and i suspect that if you wanted to
procure a signature or an inscription
you could probably do so if that
appealed to you
um could i also ask that you check to
see that all your cell phones are turned
off
and that you refrain from taking
photographs while they are speaking
and now without further ado anthony
grayling and then christopher hitchens i
think that's the order isn't that thank
you
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed george and
thank you so much to the ghetto
institute for for hosting this um
i must begin by saying uh straight away
picking up a point that uh dr ustrin
made there
about the uh
delicate aspect of this particularly in
a setting like this
from the allied point of view that is
from the point of view the western
allies the united kingdom and the united
states and the second world war was a
just war a war that had to be fought
because it was being fought against
aggressors
and there were aggressors who um and was
known at the time and uh more fully
known afterwards uh perpetrated some
horrendous atrocities some horrendous
crimes against humanity and one of the
greatest crimes that the western allies
could have committed during the course
of the war would have been to lose it
and that's a point that i'm very alive
to and it's one that we have to bear in
mind when we
pre-sinned from the larger picture of
the war and look just at our own
consciences on the allied side of the
struggle
to ask ourselves whether everything that
we did in it passes muster from the
moral point of view
is it really the case that all the
endeavors that we made all the decisions
that we made all the actions we took in
the course of that war um are
unquestionably uh good ones from the
point of view of the overall aim of the
war
um now i should just say a little bit
about how i came to write the book
because it explains in a way the the the
conclusion that the book comes to at the
end and when i was very small small boy
what i wanted to be was a spitfire pilot
in the battle of britain this was a very
common ambition on the part of small
boys in the decade or two after the
second world war and there were some
difficulties like time travel and better
eyesight and things like that that
prevented me from
fulfilling this ambition so i did the
next best thing which was to read as
much as i possibly could about the air
war
first of course about the the battle of
britain itself and then as time went by
i read more and more about the the
bombing war and
almost immediately noted that there was
a a tone of doubt a tone of uncertainty
in the historical accounts given almost
every historian of the bomber war found
it necessary to provide justifications
for one important aspect of it namely
that aspect of it which involved area
bombing of urban centers the deliberate
and systematic targeting
of thousands of tons of bombs indeed
hundreds of thousands of tons of bombs
on civilian populations
and uh as soon as i noticed that there
was this uh equivocation it
felt to me as though here was something
that had been too little discussed in a
way too much left to the concluding
chapters of these histories
and then i came across a
remark in one of them which said
this question whether it was right or
wrong
to conduct area bombing as opposed to
tactical bombing specific bombing of
genuine industrial military targets is a
question which we must leave to the
moral philosophers
and i thought well the day will come
when i i'll try to take up that
challenge and that's what i've done in
this book
and in order to take up that challenge
and in order to be scrupulously fair to
all sides of the argument about this i
felt it necessary to talk about the
history of the area bombing campaigns
which i've done in the book also to talk
about the uh intentions and the
knowledge on the part of people who
conducted it and that meant looking at
the discussion about bombing as a weapon
of war in the decades before the second
world war and i mean just to give you an
example one astonishing thing was that
in 1899 at a hague
international conference in the hague on
armaments and peace
it was decided by the international
community present there to outlaw
throwing hand grenades out of balloons
this is before there were airplanes
already it was clear coming up on the
horizon that developments in technology
were introducing uh potential weapons
and potential strategies of war that
could be tremendously destructive and so
as early as that as early as the 19th
century
this endeavor first endeavor was made
and all during the decades before the
second world war those 40 crucial years
there were repeated debates about
bombing and the experience of bombing
for example in the first world war the
germans launched a bombing campaign
against the united kingdom they sent
over zeppelins and big big airships and
gotha bombers these
gigantic bombing aircraft they killed
about 1500 people mainly as a result of
inaccurate navigation inaccurate bombing
they thought they were bombing a
a munitions factory in liverpool and
actually they were bombing a residential
district in foxton
and the result in the minds of people in
england itself was to be
horrified at the prospect of bigger
bombers and more of them with more bombs
on them
and the devastating effect that would
have on civilization
indeed so great was the fear at least on
the part of civilian minds that in the
peace conferences in geneva during the
1920s and early 1930s not only was an
endeavor made to ban bombing to outlaw
bombing in war but indeed it was at one
point mooted that flight that airplanes
should be banned on the grounds that if
there was one somebody would throw a
bomb out of it well that didn't uh um
didn't persuade anybody largely because
the militaries at the time had already
grasped the potential of bombing
um after all the british had been using
it very effectively in iraq or during
the 1920s to police the recalcitrant
tribesmen there and the person who was
in command of that bombing endeavour in
iraq was a man called arthur harris
and arthur harris was of that school of
thought
initiated by duhay and others
that bombing was an extremely potent
weapon which could bring a war to an end
very swiftly because it would terrorize
a civilian population into persuading
its own government to give up the
struggle
there were quite different thoughts
about about bombing of what bombing was
for and should be for here in the united
states of america prior to the second
world war the united states army air
force had drew up plans for howard would
conduct a bombing campaign if it got
involved in a struggle in europe and
they decided that with the smaller force
and smaller bombers targeting them their
endeavors at
genuine bottlenecks in transport in the
production of military equipment and
aircraft and very very crucially oil
supplies that they would be able to
strangle the the enemy war effort
and as it turned out and as the bombing
surveys found at the end of the second
world war that was exactly right one of
the great contributions to winning the
war in europe was made by the united
states army air force the mighty eight
based in england and the 15th based in
italy
whose most of whose endeavors were
aimed at these bottleneck targets and
for
for proof if one needed it one has only
to think of the day on which the soviet
army crossed the vistula river heading
westwards towards berlin they were met
by no fewer than twelve thousand panzers
waiting on the baron of bridgehead these
uh highly maneuverable fast tanks with
the which packed a lot of punch which
were very well manned twelve thousand of
them waiting on the baron off bridgehead
not one of them could move because they
didn't have any petrol the fuel supplies
have been had been
severely interdicted by mainly by
american bombing in the period
beforehand
now when um the war
uh seemed imminent when people realized
that it was about to break over the
heads of people in europe and this was
from the mid-1930s onwards the anxiety
about the
effect of bombing was so great that all
the major governments of europe put into
place plans um for how they would deal
with it in london for example 60 000
additional hospital beds were provided
um something like a million
uh uh
enough timber to to make a million
coffins was
set aside and in one of those tremendous
acts of futility that all bureaucracies
go in for
an extra 5 million death certificates we
issued to local authorities and this is
a measure in a way of what the anxiety
was because of course people thought
that on the very first day of war a
mighty fleet would come across the
channel
and would um bomb london flat and there
would be
millions of people trying to stream into
the countryside there would be chaos and
and there would be terror
and as it happened actually mere minutes
after neville chamberlain announced that
the united kingdom was at war with
germany
the um
air raid alarms went off in london
because a solitary french pilot had
forgotten to file his flight plan on the
way across the channel
but that too was a measure of the
anxiety that people felt about it
and against the background of that
anxiety neville chamberlain twice in the
house of commons once before the war
began and once in the in the so-called
phony war period between the actual
outbreak of war on the 10th of may when
the the germans attacked in the in the
west that twice said in the house of
commons his majesty's government will
never bomb civilians during the course
of this war
he believed uh on the authority of his
advisers that it was against
international law because
it was felt there
but by chamberlain's government as it
was felt here in the united states of
america that the
discussions that had been held in the
preceding decades in effect amounted to
something close to customer
international law and that it would be a
crime
uh
in that law to bomb civilian targets of
course uh actually the motivation for
chamberlain saying what he did
about um not bombing civilian targets
was that
britain was very underprepared for the
war and terrified that a great assault
against the cities of the united kingdom
would be mounted by germany and so he
was trying to
persuade the germans not to do it by
saying that he wouldn't do it so that
was that was an important part of the
motivation
but it was sincere enough
for obamacare to be under very strict
instructions
that its aircraft should not cross the
coast of continental europe
in case a bomb fell out of an airplane
and on to a civilian so the bombardment
wasn't even allowed to cross the coast
before the um
attack in the west on the 10th of may
1940 and after that attack and right the
way up until february 1942 and despite
the blitz which
about which the the certain things will
be said because in fact it wasn't itself
a genuine area bombing campaign it was
an attempt to paralyze the financial
administrative districts of london and
to paralyze the industrial cities like
coventry dark cities like plymouth and
so on but even despite that bomber
command was under orders not to target
civilian populations deliberately
until february 1942
but increasingly in the early years of
the war
there was more and more acceptance of
what we now call collateral damage the
fact that if you're attacking a a
military facility or or a factory in a
city your bombs are going to fall on the
people who live nearby
and the anxiety about doing that early
in the war dissipated as the morning
mist does with the sun coming up so that
by the time
the infamous director of the 14th
february 1942 was sent to bomber command
saying
your primary target from now on will be
the morale of the enemy population by
that time attitudes had changed
and i'd like to mention at this juncture
that uh you know sometimes people say
aren't you isn't this all hindsight
aren't you looking back at the war and
raising questions about it from
the comfort of and relative safety of
your armchair now in the early 21st
century which my reply is that two and a
half thousand years ago
um thucydides in writing about the
peloponnesian war said
uh i want to recount the history of this
war in order to show how moral
sensibility is coarsened by war how when
you're engaged in the struggle you care
less and less as time goes by about what
you do and you gave as uh
the the
sort of killer example of this the
difference between the athenians
attitude to michelini early in the war
maitelini was a city on lesbos which had
breached the treaty that it had with
athens and the athenians discussed the
question whether in punishment they
should massacre the population of
michelini if they had bombers they would
have done it that way but
in those days they didn't they decided
against it they decided not to massacre
the population mainly for prudential
reasons but the fact that they had the
debate at all uh had behind it a moral
impulse
but 12 years later when the city of
milos wouldn't play ball with athens
there was no debate the population was
massacred and thucydides wanted people
to be alert to this fact of the
courseling effect of war and it's a
lesson that applies not just to the
second world war into the bomber's story
in that war but uh to us
at all points in our history including
now
anyway 14th of february 1942 the
primary
task of bomber command was to
attack the morale of the enemy
population that meant systematic and
repeated
attacks on urban areas on civilian
populations with the express purpose of
killing and terrorizing as many of them
as possible
because the um
the kind of aircraft like the big
lancaster and halifax are sterling four
engine bombers which would carry
tremendous bomb loads twice the bomb
load of a b-17 flying fortress
and the kind of weaponry because that
was still in in process and it wasn't
really until 1943 that uh sarva harris
had the the weapon that he wanted to
carry out this anti-morale campaign
against the german population it was
only then in 1943 that the really great
raids happened and the first of them was
the
um very aptly named operation gomorrah
which took place in late july early
august 1943 and in which the very first
fire um storm occurred and it's been
very eloquently written about by w.g
zebolt in his uh um essay the natural
history of destruction
and there he points out
how many people of the about 40 000
people who were killed in that one night
were asphyxiated in their cellars and in
their air raid shelters
how many of them caught in the open in
the firestorm were so severely burned
that their bodies shrank from adult size
to the size of babies or dolls
how many people were picked up by the
firestorm burning and and flung away in
the vortex of these terrible winds these
were frightful frightful effects of the
bombing
and the point about them is that they
were deliberate because the royal air
force thought very carefully about what
his bomb load would be like it'd have 25
percent high explosives 75 percent in
centuries these incendiaries had an
early form of napalm petroleum jelly
phosphorus bituminous substances and oil
soaked rags
and the phosphorus if it splashed as it
did it was designed to splash over a
very wide area if it splashed onto a
human being that person would begin to
burn very fiercely and they might as
thousands of people did in hamburg throw
themselves into the canals to put out
the flames only to find to their horror
that when they got out of the water it
would reignite spontaneously
it was a a terrible
collection of weapons that were dropped
with the aim of doing as much
harm as possible to the civilian
population in those cities
now these facts and that they are they
are terrible facts could be countered by
saying look war is terrible
you know horrible things happen in war i
mean it's a war to the death and a war
against the very formidable and wicked
enemy as the nazi regime was
you know the
the gloves are off
and this has sometimes been very very
well expressed in a chilling phrase by
no lesser person than mao zedong
who once said
war is not crochet
and everything that follows from that
follies
and when people say this to me my
response to them is to say
uh
would that mean that it's okay in the
course of a war to bayonet babies
which is a sort of shocking thought a
shocking thing to say and most people
say
well no of course not
and most people would agree that
something like milai in vietnam
was a crime
which implies that there are limits and
that instantly raises the question where
do the limits lie
and it raises the further question
was the systematic bombing of civilian
populations in germany and japan
beyond the limits
and to examine that question and my the
book is dedicated to george and i
haven't got much time but but very very
briefly what i have to do and try to do
in the book is to look at the uh the
argument that says um no it wasn't
belong but beyond the limits in the
context of the war that is that if there
was a genuine military necessity if it
really helped to win the war then that
fact trumps our moral scruples about
doing this
and so that becomes the key focus of the
discussion really to ask whether it
really did help to win the war
and the answer is
that it didn't
people say that by by bombing the cities
keeping the workers awake when when they
weren't killed
making life difficult for
the german population and administration
as a whole because of the disruption
caused by bombing that it must have done
something to slow down to dent german
production
it must also of course have kept forces
back in germany anti-aircraft forces
troops and aircraft to defend against
these attacks
the second of those two arguments can be
very quickly and simply met which is to
say that no matter what you were bombing
even if you were bombing transport and
factories and military installations and
roads they would have had to keep back
anti-aircraft guns and aircraft so that
doesn't defend area bombing attacks on
civilians
but as to the the question of industrial
production
industrial production of all kinds not
just military production
increased year-on-year in germany until
the end of 1944.
the german economy which was very very
strong by the time war broke out and
which as a result of conquest in central
and and eastern europe had vast manpower
resources vast natural resources
available to it following those
conquests
was never put on a war footing
it it was never the case that a single
german woman was conscripted into a
factory to make weapons as was the case
for example in britain
there was so much labor
that could be drafted in from from
eastern europe slave labor and prisoner
labor
that there was never any necessity for
it and production of all things
including luxury items and bubble beds
and flower pots and all the rest of it
went on and on right until the end of
1944 and what stopped it was the drying
up of fuel coal and oil
and gas
and that was the result of
attempts at precision bombing tactical
daylight bombing very dangerous by the
united united states army air force
it will only as it happens uh those of
you who've read about this will know
really affected from very late 1943 and
1944 certainly onwards because
of the mustang fighter aircraft
long-range fighter aircraft could fly
all the way from the east uh coast of
england to berlin and back and could
protect the bombers and it was in fact
the mustangs and lightnings that
accompanied the bomber fleets which have
fought the luftwaffe out of the sky and
d-day there were something like 12 000
allied aircraft
uh in operation over france and
something like uh 800 luftbuffer
aircraft to defend against them
and so the the effect that that the
united states endeavors had in the
european theater was a very considerable
one
so that the major argument that the area
bombing that is bombing civilian
populations by night
was a major factor in helping to win the
war looks very questionable
now just to be brief because i'm sure
i'm running overtime i must turn
attention to the american endeavors in
the pacific theater
and there i'm afraid the united states
went 180 degrees
in the opposite direction from what
they've done in the european theater
there's no question of precision bombing
in japan once the mariana islands had
been captured and airfields built there
so that the main islands of japan were
within range of the of the pacific
bombing force under the direction of
curtis lemay
uh a well-known name i think
there was hardly any japanese air force
left at that time and and precious
little anti-aircraft defense on the
ground in mainland japan and so curtis
lemay told his flyers to strip out the
guns the the um
defenses uh of the aircraft themselves
since they just made the aircraft
heavier to fill them up with incendiary
bombs and to bomb from a low altitude
and to burn the cities of japan
and this he did systematically in the
last eight months or so nine months of
the war
and the first great incendiary attack
was on tokyo on the 19th of march 1945
when 85 000 people were burned to death
in that city
i was told by
an email correspondent just before i
flew over the atlantic to come here
about the work that was done at the
dugway proving grounds in utah near salt
lake city prior to the bombing campaign
over japan where replicas of wooden
japanese houses were built so that they
could test which kind of incendiary bomb
would burn it most effectively and so
the the the campaign was of course a
well thought out and and deliberate one
and it was a tremendously destructive
one
in the um nine months or so of the of
the bombing of japan as many people were
killed and wounded in japan among the
civilian population
as were killed and wounded in germany by
bombing in the whole of the war so about
350 000 dead and about 800 000 injured
in in both cases although the figures of
course obey approximate
and i suppose the final point about the
united states army air force endeavors
in the in the pacific theater is
that more than four months before the
atom bombs were dropped on the 69th of
august 945
the japanese had begun to make overtures
for a truce for a ceasefire
they were doing it through the russians
who weren't at that time at war with
them the russians only declared war in
japan on the 6th of august 1945 when it
was going to be an easy land grab you
still have some of the japanese islands
as you know
and so the japanese made overtures to
the united states through
through the russians
and there was one condition and that was
that they could keep the emperor
but you may remember that roosevelt and
churchill had decided the casablanca
that there were to be no conditions and
this was used
some people say as an excuse by the
truman administration
not to talk to the japanese about a
ceasefire until the atom bombs have been
dropped
to the very very great credit of a man
called henry simpson who was secretary
of defense in the roosevelt
administration he tried to dissuade
truman from dropping
a bomb on a populated city he said drop
one of them on an uninhabited island to
show what the weapon can do
but uh his suggestion wasn't taken
and so he struck
the word kyoto off the list of possible
targets of the atom bombs because he
knew of the significance of that city
now i'm looking back on it now from this
perspective and this is my final point
one notices that in the immediate
aftermath of the war
that is in the years of 1945 1949
tremendous endeavors were made by the
international community by the world as
a whole you might say uh to try to push
in place
a framework of of law or at very least
of principles which would make the
things that had happened during the
course of the war impossible i mean that
was the uh that that was the ideal that
people set themselves when they um wrote
and and agreed upon the united nations
declaration universal declaration of
human rights for example and it was
certainly the aim of the fourth geneva
convention which was uh written and
signed in 1949 the convention on the
protection of civilians in war
that convention in its draft form had in
it some clauses which specifically
protect civilians from attacks by
bombing
and the british and the americans
refused to have those clauses included
because to agree to them would have been
a retrospective admission of guilt
of something that they'd
done during the course of the war
it wasn't until 1977 that a protocol was
added to that convention
specifically outlawing bombing attacks
on civilians
the british government signed it
your own government
and i'm not entirely sure of the of the
the technicality it may be that it was
never signed by the united states
government or has not been ratified by
congress but it generated not taken to
be in force from washington's point of
view to this day
which makes this whole question really
about the deliberate and systematic
massacre bombing of civilian populations
a live issue still
during the war itself by the way in the
united kingdom there was a very very
vigorous campaign of opposition to
aerial bombing
um questions were asked in the house of
commons and in the house of lords bishop
bell of chichester repeatedly said in
the house of lords we're fighting
barbarians why are we behaving like them
too
and the mass observation unit which was
a podium organization in the uk that
kept its finger on the pulse of public
opinion during the war kept on asking
people in all all around the country
what they thought about being bombed and
about bombing and whether we should bomb
in retaliation for the attacks on on us
and people in the
cities that have been badly bombed
majorities of people in cities that have
been badly bombed said no don't bomb
their cities
and people in cities that hadn't been
bombed the door said yes
bomb them
and that's a very interesting fact about
attitudes at the time there was full
knowledge of of what was going on if you
read newspaper reports now all the way
through 943 44 and 45 you see that
there were very explicit reports about
what had been attacked how many bombs
had been dropped there were headlines in
the telegraph newspaper for example
saying last night uh dusseldorf and god
montoys received 60 coventries
in other words a bomb weight 60 times as
great as had been received in coventry
in november 1940.
so
people knew what was happening at the
time
the people who were running the country
had read their thucydides at school and
university and they knew the arguments
from two and a half thousand years
before and all the way through the great
tradition of uh ethical thinking in in
in the west
and so
in many ways there are no places to hide
except behind the arguments that i very
briefly alluded to and discussed a much
greater length in the book about the the
military and industrial justifications
that are profited in defense of the area
bombing i don't think those defenses
work and i think therefore
very serious question marks rise above
that campaign
and the reason why it's relevant to
discuss it today is because
although we don't i don't think that
there's much point in pointing fingers
and calling people war criminals now
after the event or indeed impugning the
courage and tremendous sacrifice that
was made by young airmen in the war who
thought
rightly that they were fighting a just
war and that they had the support of
their majority of their populations
behind them
there's no point in that but there is
every point in trying to draw lessons
from it for now just when in our world
we are beginning to find ways of trying
to enforce some of these international
instruments
that were the result of the second world
war like
a human rights framework and like the
protections of civilians in times of war
which because of the kinds of weapons
that we have now is ever more important
a question
thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
i'd like to thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen for coming my name and
heron i'd like to thank the gerder
institute for
inviting me also
um
i think i too should
respond a little to um
that's to say if my glasses on my head
they were here a second ago oh you are
so kind thank you
i'm sorry this is not a throat clearing
um it's not a plea for
plea for sympathy uh
i expected
uh
dr ustrin to say something like
that and for anthony to take him up on
it professor grayling i should say
i think it's time really that we said
look
we have been all of us very impressed by
the extreme seriousness
with which germany has accepted its
post-war responsibilities and discussed
them in public in its own country and
international forum
there is absolutely no reason at all to
suspect
that any reopening of this discussion
which has already been quite
elaborately uh
undertaken in germany even uh gunter
grass with his new novel the crab walk
has broken a few things that were once
to do there's no reason at all to
suspect that germany would become
intoxicated by any uh vengeance
uh fantasy or any grievance or any
spurious
moral equivalence there's nothing to
apologize for in other words in the
opening of this
discussion and all of us british and
american i think should have said this a
long time ago
i very much congratulate professor
grading on very lucid summary
of his own book that's not as easy to do
actually summarizing your own work as
some people might think um and i don't i
know he won't uh
penalize me for saying that much of the
argument was at least to some extent
familiar to some of you even if not at
the very elevated level
at which he presented it which enables
me to freeze me to
propose a few ironic
references
to it
i was going to start where he ended and
i'll be brief by saying that
not only has this argument i mean york
friedrich in his book debra and this is
only the most recent in germany but this
time has been going on in britain for a
very long time and did in fact begin i
think rather to the credit of my fellow
countrymen if i may say that
uh during the war not just to bishop
ralph bell chichester who raised the
question in parliament as did others
not just vera britain whose
extraordinary book on the subject is
still very much imprinted very much
debated
but
someone i'm proud to say was a friend of
mine the late tom dreiberg actually he
died in noble as lord bradwell socialist
though he was
was at the time um a very important
newspaper colonist in london and in his
column in the daily express
revealed the case of a german girl named
hilda
who had been orphaned every single
person she knew not just all her family
everyone she knew had gone and been
burned to death
in the german city and he he opened his
collar with a big picture of her and the
question right across the page in 1944 i
think should we be bombing hilda
and this was a live discussion in
parliament in the church uh in clubs and
pubs and places of work and in bomb
cities and it was right to have all
these qualms
and misgivings then and if it was right
to have them then we don't need to
apologize for having them now
oh so sorry zuckerman i remember reading
it this when i was quite young
very shocked
lord charwell's memorandum to winston
churchill
saying i think i've worked out how we
could crack their morale what we need to
do is to find the working-class quarters
of the german cities where the houses
are packed closer together and where we
would get as it were as americans would
now vulgarly say more bangs for the buck
we can really slaughter them in these
working-class quarters
uh lord charwell's the
chilling uh memorandum of churchill so
sorry zuckerman one of the other
directors of this program
of bombing after the war wanted to write
a piece about it a reflection on it
for cyril connolly's great cultural
magazine horizon
and he decided on a visit to cologne
which was a city he'd had a hand in
flattening
and he came back and was interviewed
visited by somebody who said well what
about the piece he said i can't do it
i can't do anything about it i've seen
cologne now and i can't write
so what i can remember is seeing the
total destruction of the cathedral
and seeing a human finger on the
top of a pile of rubble
and i'm i've got writer's block about
the subject um he said i had a title at
least
and the title was going to be on the
natural history of destruction
later and next by the great german
writer w g several who and nielsen
mentioned
who we were very privileged to have
amongst us in britain for
many decades as a writer and a teacher
uh
i stipulate therefore that i absolutely
know what professor grading is talking
about
and the most haunting thing in his book
i think is the one he didn't draw
attention to which is this
obama command and to some extent um the
united states army air force did this to
germany in the closing years of the war
for one reason above all
because they could do it
they did it because they could
they weren't able to do it earlier in
the war when it might who knows i'm
going to come to that
have made a difference but by this stage
that was what they knew how to do had
built the equipment for had trained 400
first talk they were going to do it
it's not unlike the very gruesome moment
at the end of the first um
uh gulf war with saddam hussein actually
i believe that that was that's one long
war myself i think it's been going on
since 1991 and only
uh recently been concluded but um let's
call it the first girl for 91 where
saddam's forces were withdrawing from
kuwait
got themselves trapped in a huge traffic
jam with a lot of other stragglers as
you may remember in the mutlab pass
on the way back to iraq that convoy was
bombed and staffed for days for hours
days by uh
american fighters and bombers who
couldn't believe their luck from
aircraft carriers anchored not far away
including the uss
ranger why did they blast them because
they could they didn't blast the
republican guard and was the pity they
didn't take out saddam hussein was the
pity but they could do this to the
iraqis and some kuwaitis too well we
have to live with this
we have to be intensely serious about it
i had to go and give a talk at the raf
club in london the other day on another
matter
and i i felt the qualm i always feel
when i go on to the premises of the ref
the picture of marshall harris on the
wall things of this kind i was brought
up to think of fighter commanders the
heroes as anthony was bomber command
always been a bit more difficult for us
um but i have a i have an anecdote i'm
just going to tell you now
which
i think makes the history of the raf
imperishable though most raf people
don't know about it
the midnight of the century
as we old comrades call it
the midnight of the century is the
hitler-style impact
the worst moment
in the history of civilization the
handshake between molotov and ribbondrop
the raising of the swastika flag over
moscow airport the singing of the horst
vessel lead on moscow radio
uh the embrace of the two dictators the
crushing of poland
between them the destruction of the
baltic uh abolition really of the
boarding states and the preparation for
a ghastly war well
mr mortoff was back in berlin because
the alliance went on
well into the 40s as you know on one
barmy night
in late 1940 early 1941 and he had to
take shelter
with his ghastly nazi hosts because the
raf
had arrived on a rather poultry raid but
it was enough to send the nazis
and their guests rather embarrassed down
into the shelter and while molotov was
there
with his nazi friends he said i thought
you told me this could not happen i
don't think the pilots knew
how brilliantly they had performed on
this occasion but if you allow yourself
to think about this rather magnificent
moment where it's britain's airmen
against hitler and stalin combined
bring mantle's the
english cheek with a great blush of
pride
uh
then you reflect on you have to you are
obliged to reflect on the following
two years before a group of germans who
when we are known we we know them by
their
some of them by their individual names
uh some of them by their um collective
name the kreizer group
a group of very important german
soldiers and diplomats and officers and
civilian politicians
grouped around the heroic i think
especially heroic
general helmut von mulker
ludwig beck was another member of it and
canaris was briefly a member i believe
at my old college in oxford we had an
annual commemoration for adam von trot
zusaltz who was a another member of it
later to give his life hideously the in
the plot to kill hitler in 1944. they
weren't they sent an envoy to neville
chamberlain
and said if you and your foreign
minister mr halifax if you will
guarantee that you will stand by
czechoslovakia in other words if you
will say that in moving to
czechoslovakia means war
we can decapitate the nazi regime and
tell the german people we have saved
them not just from
the foul dictator but from war as well
that we have struck for peace as well as
for democracy but we need your guarantee
that you will fight for czechoslovakia
before we can act
the risk these gentlemen took in making
this move
is something that's very difficult to
imagine as a matter of quality
and bravery and they were told forget it
we like the present situation in germany
we hope rather to make an alliance with
it against
stalin against communism
and as trotsky was the first to point
out once they made that pact in munich
with hitler ignoring
the opposition in germany
they made the hitler-style impact
inevitable
so that the whole might of britain
and air
navy and military which was exerted on
hitler's side in 1938
should later be used to bomb and destroy
german civilians
is a conclusion that's inescapable very
slowly pointed out
and if you like impossible to live with
and to make it worse we find
within a few years of this that the
obliteration of the city of dresden
one of the most extraordinary
achievements of european civilization
the entire obliteration of it and most
of its people
is being justified
for one reason and one reason alone
if we do it it will impress joseph
stalin whose forces are pressing in
on the other end now i think if you're
going to destroy
a cultural treasure treasure house
and and ignite a firestorm that is
designed to consume
all of the people in it
you had better have a better reason than
it might bring a smile to joseph
stalin's face
and this is not part of our official
history this is not what we're taught in
school
ladies and gentlemen in england inherent
i can assure you
now
um
how to confront these uh
i hope i've connected them for you
these multiple imbricated
crimes and ironies and
tragedies how to make sense of it the
way i propose to do it is is this
by imagining myself not as an englishman
or an angry american but as a german
which i'd be proud to be in in fact on
my mother's side through
the city of breslau going back quite a
long way now um i am
um i was brought up in the immediate
aftermath of the second world war in
plymouth
and portsmouth i remember being told not
to play on the bomber sites i remember
seeing
the ruins uh the smell that still went
on actually of the on
the un
dug out uh collapsed buildings and so i
remember i remember the devastation was
it was the scene of my upbringing i also
remember the little island of malta
where i was partly brought up to which
is almost totally destroyed it's
beautiful capital valletta almost
completely destroyed by the air forces
of
hitler and mussolini especially remember
the awful wreckage of the of the royal
opera house in the center of the city
but
and my father was a member of the royal
navy and had a very tough time indeed
in the north atlantic and elsewhere um
on boxing day if you care uh
1942 his ship sank the scharnhorst
which was about to
undertake a terrible campaign against
civilian shipping in the north sea it's
a better day's work than i've ever done
i mentioned it just in cases of interest
but in my heart and sinew
i feel german about this
and if i can
commit the embarrassment
of mentioning
the following names not in the same
breath of as my own of course
i hope i'll make my point i'm thinking
of thomas mann
i'm thinking of pastor niemoller and
duchy bonhoeffer the great catholic the
great excuse of great protestant
resistors of france jaeger starter who
was executed rather than
uh join hitler's army as a catholic he
was an austrian i'm mentioning austrians
to ernst fisher who broadcast from
moscow against the advances of the
vermont uh in
russia um chancellors willie brandt and
bruno kreiske who left their own
countries and joined the uh armed forces
of others rather than surrender
uh to fascism kurt schumacher
some of you will know some of these
names all of them i think should be
uh made imperishable in our history as
well as that of germany
and austria and these of course are
heroes i'm talking about but how many
heroes do you think
that might have been who will whose
names we'll never know in say hamburg
a city that had always withstood the
national socialists
that had always remained as it were red
and democratic
how many people who carried within
themselves the seeds of a future germany
and better germany
were destroyed by the raf we used to
have
a question a rather smug one in england
after the war where were all the good
germans all this time well one answer to
that i'm very sorry to say as many of
them were buried and burned alive by the
royal air force
and the fact
has to be faced but
uh
now look at it the other way
um we got
billy wilder
albert einstein
theodore dorno
marlena dietrich
sigmund freud and the germans got julius
striker
in exchange for the uh the collapse of
civilization that was undertaken by
nazism and i now come to another name
that of victor klemperer could i just
get an idea of how many of you in the
room know know who i'm talking about
oh that's admirable well
for those on c-span then if i can uh
media conscious hitchens um
victor klemper the cousin i think of the
famous conductor otto was a german jew
convert to uh protestantism married to a
german protestant woman professor of
french
language and literature at the
university of dresden and on the first
day of the third reich he decided to
keep a diary and he kept it every single
day
until 1933 he's the only man of whom we
can read over every single day of the
third reich
it's called i will bear witness don't
start reading it late at night would be
my advice
do not start reading it later tonight
because you know what's coming and he
doesn't so when they take away his cat
because aryan cats are not allowed to
live in partly jewish homes seriously
when they take away his job when they
take away his rational book when they
make him wear the star when they say you
can't now use the tram you can't now use
the bus
all this humiliation
uh you know it's going to get only
steadily worse
and you're only encouraged by the fact
that almost every day he reports that a
member of the german working class comes
up to him and says cheer up nate these
bastards will soon be gone
don't worry we're with you the
scoundrels can't last much longer
the way he listens to the radio the way
he looks at the newspapers uh the way he
he disproves if you like the daniel
jonah goldhagen thesis which i regard as
a defamation of the german people
and of their history
the the the vile
collectivization of guilt that's
involved in the willing executioner
but the for all the friendship he's
shown
the machine grinds on and on
and finally it's come time to deport the
last element to the east the ones who
have aryan wives german wives or
husbands the last ones they get round to
and he's moved into a holding camp in
the middle of president
on i think the night of the 12th of
february
with his wife and the next day it's on
the train but that night the heavens
open
anyone who's reading account of what
happened in dresden that night doesn't
need any
words from me
the terrible thing according to
frederick taylor's book is the climatic
conditions were even better than they
had hoped it succeeded too well it
wasn't just a firestorm it was i think
it's justifiable to use the term
holocaust which many people object to
because it means the total destruction
of something by fire i do not believe it
should be called a final solution or an
endless song as the germans would say
that would be quite untrue but yes a
massive destruction by fire and in the
morning there's no authority in dresden
anymore
and there's no one to take him to the
train with his wife
and they peel off their yellow stars
she's made to wear one too and they set
off for their home and start looking for
the red army it's over it's completely
over there's no one to give orders and
there's no one who will take them
anymore
the only thing i think in our collective
experience and imagination that one
could call upon is general sherman's
decision to lay waste to the confederacy
to make sure that not one brick is piled
upon another until it is understood who
is master now and who has lost and to
make that conclusive
i think it would have been better if
anthony had dealt in his book with the
psychological effect of the years of the
thousand year reich
it had to be utterly disproved
that there was a leader who was
all-powerful and all-knowing
as so many were willing to believe
it had to be conclusively shown that
when they said we will never allow
bomber in our own skies that they were
completely wrong do i have a minute to
read something from thomas mann yeah
thomas mann wasn't jewish
thomas was not jewish as you know but he
decided he couldn't live in germany
under these conditions and in his great
novel i think dr foster's
published i think first 947 he he plays
the part of a german watching what's
happening he says describing the the
finnish germany of the us
aaf and the raf he says this earth
shaking
plummeting havoc has come breathtakingly
close to my refuge several times now
the dreadful bombardment of the city of
jura and vilabel perkheimer was no
longer some distant event
and as the last judgment fell upon
munich as well i sat here in my study
turning ashen
shaking like the walls
and doors of my house
its famous publishing district is i
sadly hear only a heap of rubble and an
immeasurable wealth of literary and
educational material is now the spoil of
destruction a loss not only for us
germans
but also for a whole world that cares
about culture
that world however is apparently willing
to take the loss into the bargain
granted he says the destruction of our
cities from the air has long since
turned germany into an arena of war and
yet we find it inconceivable
impermissible to think
that germany should ever again sorry
could ever become could ever become such
an arena in the true sense
and our propaganda has a curious way of
warning the foe
against incursion upon our soil our
sacred german soil as if that would be
some grizzly atrocity
our sacred german soil
as if anything was still sacred about it
as if it had not long ago been
desecrated again and again
by the immensity of our rape of justice
and did not lie naked
both morally and in fact before the
power of divine judgment let it come
says man
and then he says when he thinks about
wurzburg and all the beautiful gem-like
cities of germany being turned into
powder and ash this is terrible he said
but i but i cannot allow myself to
forget
that
terrible though german defeat is it is
nothing compared to the thought the
horror of german victory
he's willing to come to terms with he
seems almost to invite something that is
a judgment against which no appeal can
ever be made
it's finished there's going to be no
myth this time that we could have won if
we'd hung on a couple more years
that we were stabbed in the back by the
jews they certainly weren't by then
that the the the cretinous homosexuals
and communists and uh pacifists
undermine german morale no no no no
excuses this time it's over you have
conclusively lost and
we can now begin to reconstruct german
democracy and culture and civilization
which we did don't let it be
forgotten sibled in his book which i
greatly admire refers to a war of
annihilation i think he should have not
deployed that word did not annihilate
germany
british and american soldiers did not
commit atrocities against german
civilians hitler's former allies in the
red army committed the most appalling
atrocities on german civilians but if
you lie down with the devil in that way
this is what you have to expect
we have everything to be proud of it
seems to me
in the resilience of the german people
who re-emerged from the rubble very
quickly
uh without self-pity uh without
resentment without conspiracy theories
to begin in this task of reconstructing
not only
germany but also a europeanized germany
and a democratic europe in which germany
still has
pride place
uh as a centerpiece um in economics in
culture in publishing and democracy
and it's something of which we're all
all of us consider ourselves friends of
the german people
rightly proud justified be proud
i do not myself believe that without
i won't call it a war of annihilation
but without an annihilating conclusive
incontestable utter victory of the kind
that sherman imposed on slavery that
when the slaves were freed from the
camps
that when the clampers could walk again
in the street without the yellowstone
there wasn't that day of feeling of
liberation
heinrich burl in his closing letter to
his sons the one he wanted them to read
after he died his
posthumous letter to his sons
one of the greatest german authors of
all time i think says my boys
you will as you grow up always know
what to think of any of your fellow
countrymen according as to whether they
describe
april 1945 as the month of german
liberation or german defeat never forget
this neither should we
now in closing
i've got to say
two things about anthony's book that
gravely disappointed me and that he
didn't mention himself one
i think that he should not have said
that it would have been right for the
air crews of the american and british
air forces to refuse to obey these
orders
i think it is of the first importance in
the time of warfare
uh when the when civilian and democratic
government is not just in command but at
stake where its existence is at stake
that the civilian and elected
governments have the right
to assume that they know the larger
strategic picture
and that their or their orders will be
obeyed
and i think the suggestion that there
should have been a mutiny in the middle
of a war against the third reich
is an immoral one and i think you should
withdraw it
i think it was entirely right for those
orders to be obeyed whatever the doubts
may have been because it was it is not
the place of officers to take to take
the place
of members of parliament
and the british cabinet
and then i'm going to have to read
a chapter which excuse me a paragraph
that i think disfigures the book
uh and i'll just quickly do this and i
think then it really will be time for me
to end my
hostage taking of this audience um
anthony says
a surprise attack on a civilian
population
aimed at causing maximum hurt shock
disruption and terror
there comes to see very little
difference in principle between the
raf's operation gomorrah
or the usaf bomb attacks on hiroshima
and nagasaki and the destruction of the
world trade center in new york by
terrorists on 11th of september 2001
and this latter
prescienting from differences in scale
and the drama of the target is no
different in turn
from terrorist bombings carried out in
madrid by basque separatists or nunded
by the ira all these all these there's
an amalgam here
terrorist attacks or atrocities
consisting in deliberate mass murder of
civilians to hurt and coerce
the society they belong to to say that
the principle underlying 911 hamburg and
hiroshima is the same as to say
that the same moral judgment applies to
all three i'm sorry i won't pass that i
won't take that
uh the the terrorist organization
which is also a criminal multinational
corporation
a secret society uh a fanatical
religious cult and many of things
run by osama bin laden is replying to no
offence committed against itself
it's not attempting to protect or defend
its own civilians
uh it can is concerned with other
people's civilians only to the extent
that only to the extent only to the
extent that casualties in their ranks
may be maximized to the greatest
possible
extent there has not even a jot or
tittle of justification on any strategic
matter i think it's quite indecent to
mention these things
in the same breath i think spurious
moral equivalence is the thing that must
at all costs be avoided in this argument
and i do hope
that that sentence isn't in the book
when it's published
in germany very well thank you very much
comrades and thank you anthony for
putting up with me
[Applause]
which are these workings
oh i see oh i see this one
oh yeah okay okay so i can hold this
like that
am i gonna use this next to
carrying voice
there you go
is that okay is it is it echoing is that
okay rich that's all right okay
well i i think it would be only fair to
to start this the next section of this
by by offering the floor back to anthony
if you would like to respond to to um
the last couple of points that
christopher made um and then i have a
question that i would want to ask both
of you and then and then we certainly
can open it up to questions from the
floor
well there are a number of things in
that that very rich and eloquent uh um
presentation by by um hitch there that i
that i'd love to respond to but i'll
pick out two uh which i think uh
perhaps the most significant the first
is um
on the question of the annihilating
attack the the definitive defeat of
germany the fact that
the germans must know that they've been
you know
smashed and they've got to start
absolutely from from scratch
um
one one thing that struck me as i was
working on the book was the fact that
roosevelt and churchill had signed only
very shortly afterwards to rescind a
plan that had been put forward by the
secretary of the treasury here in the
united states in roosevelt's
administration a man called
henry morgenthau this is known as the
morgenthau plan
and this plan was devised against the
background of much discussion most of it
which went on here in in the us about
what to do about germany after the war
and these discussions were of
all kinds they ranged from very extreme
um ideas that uh
you know the german people should be
sterilized so there won't be any more of
them in future uh to uh let's take all
the german children out of germany put
them into australia and places where
they could learn crickets and when they
went back to england they were you know
back to germany they behaved themselves
the idea was to try and extirpate
prussian militarism to try to get rid of
the culture that had twice plunged the
world into war in a single generation
morgethal's idea was that germany should
be de-industrialized the war should be
handed over to france and
the netherlands and luxembourg and so on
and it should be divided into two purely
aggrega agrarian countries purely
agricultural countries
roosevelt and churchill signed this but
they were told by their respective
foreign secretaries henry stimson and
anthony eden what a very very bad idea
this was eden pointed out to churchill
that a reconstructed germany was going
to be vital for europe it was going to
be vital as a bulwark against the soviet
union because that was going to be the
next big threat um and it was vital as a
trading partner anyway for for britain
itself and so the the idea was torn up
but the fact that it was put forward at
all the fact that it got as far as it
did in the debate
is
speaks volumes really about a whole
background of opinion that had its
influence indirectly on the conduct of
the bombing campaigns
now just before i get to the the second
point that uh i need to address
the
remember this that we're talking here
about one aspect of the bombing campaign
well it happened to be more than fifty
percent of what the raf did and that is
area bombing deliberate attacks on
civilians to massacre and terrorize
civilians
that aspect of the bombing campaign
was fueled by the sense that when you
bomb a city
you don't only bomb the people in it but
you bomb the schools the libraries the
concert halls the archives the monuments
the art galleries the places where they
make violins places where they record
music
in other words you bomb the culture
in the book i call it culture side the
idea that you could exterminate
the
uh
the culture as well as the people in
order to smash it and and start afresh
and this ties in very much with with
them hitches idea about an annihilating
defeat that would make it possible for
them to to start refresh and to do it
right and i think as many people did
during the war itself meant in the seed
of chaos that wonderful pamphlet that
very britain wrote she makes the point
that there are plenty of people in
germany who weren't supporters of the
nazis you know as it says the the the
city of hamburg had been the center of
opposition to nazism and yet it suffered
the first
very
big attack annihilating attack that our
obama command had mounted and so what
was happening was that the people who
were going to be needed and the
resources that were going to be needed
the clinics and schools and books and
music halls that were going to be needed
in the reconstruction effort afterwards
were being destroyed in the process and
so one has to one has to put a question
mark over that that's the first point
the second point i must take up the
direct challenge about my 9 11 analogy
i was trying there very carefully by
making the point about prescinding from
from other uh considerations on which by
the way i agree absolutely with hitch
there's a very big difference between
the british and the raf that was
carrying out that policy uh in in 1943
1944 45 and osama bin laden and his
criminal
fraternity
carrying out the 9 11 attack of course
there is that goes with that saying but
the point that i wanted to make was this
that if you think it is a bad thing that
anybody should try to kill and terrorize
civilians non-competence in order to
coerce their government or to do harm to
their polity
by carrying out an attack of that kind
then you've got to be consistent and
you've got to recognize that that on
that particular point there is a
comparability between
deliberately and systematically
attacking civilians in cities
as we did in germany and japan during
the war so i'm going to stick with that
argument
christopher do you want to
follow on that very
quickly yes if if the bombing
or indeed if the war aim in general
because it would have been consistent
with precision bombing as well
had been to impose the morganthan plan i
don't think it would possibly be
defensible
um
so i
simply in a way want a signal agreement
with anthony about that except that it
was not the policy it was very i think
it was actually disowned before the
intervention of surrounding eden and
others because in my memory of reading
the churchill
roosevelt correspondence in of their
meeting in quebec and so anyone can
check this if they wish it's the quebec
meeting
it's discussed roosevelt
says this is what morgenthau thinks
what do you think churchill says sounds
like a good idea to me they go on rather
uneasily
and i think it's it reads to me like a
competition which is which of them is
going to be the first to say actually
did we just agree to that
or not churchill is at any rate the
first he says it sounds to me
i remember his words he says immoral and
unchristian i don't see what's
unchristian about mass murder i have to
say but um
but there you go that's how some people
talk
um
anyway it it would not would have been
also by the way a very very much stiffer
and wider
opposition in britain and america
to this politically and for the
excellent reason that what it really is
the morgantown plan is a replay of the
west side treaty
the attempt to humiliate germany and
crush and squeeze its economy about
which lord cain's very famously written
his economic consequences of the peace
and uh indeed an outcome for which many
people partly rightly blame the rise of
nazism in the first place
so i think any attempt to repeat that
blunder would have been met with a very
stern in public and democratic
opposition
but as it happens we didn't have to
worry about that
um i'll just have to repeat a little
more sternly i think the point about uh
and you didn't take me up on mutiny but
maybe you didn't want to or mutiny on
telling them
our guys should have disappeared oh
right yeah okay i'll respond to just
that i have a point because i can't
believe that you would let it slide yeah
but on the um on the second point um
uh
which was
i don't know 911
yes look um
the
the action of a non-state actor
who's announced in who's announced
policy
is not the rebellion against an empire
however crudely conducted which is the
case in your analogy with the irish
republican army or the basque
eta
uh fighting however criminally in their
tactics for the
for what they conceive of as the
sufferings and losses of their people
but rather announced in advance by al
qaeda and its supporters as the attempt
to impose an empire
in fact to do worse than that to
rediscover and restore a lost and
vanished empire the caliphate on
everyone in the world to install a
universal dictatorship and to show that
its means and its ends are exactly
symmetrical because it cares nothing for
the life of anyone who isn't a true
believer this is not comparable to
anything that the royal air force did
it's just not to be mentioned in the
same breath
and i've i've totally run out of
patience with all the liberal and left
excuses for this stuff
people who think that osama bin laden is
some voice of the oppressed
or cry of the unheard that's all balls
okay
uh he wants east timor given back to
indonesia
uh a country a little country already
almost suffered genocide that indonesian
muslim hands he wasn't given back
uh he his people blew up the un
ambassador to iraq because he the great
international civil servant
sergio dimelio had overseen the
independence of east timor in its
transition they murdered him for that
as an infidel
look what they did to afghanistan pitch
hits you you're right
i don't know we're looking at with with
with belong
fascism and we're looking fascism in the
face with this guy and yes i think his
defeat should be obliterating total
final and humiliating too and i'd like a
bit of applause for that please just for
the audience on the tv thanks
not enough applause sorry
this is washington
it is it's very very interesting what
hitch has done he said he he he thinks
that it was a good thing that the defeat
of germany was an annihilating defeat um
i agree with that i think that the
defeat needed to be complete and
definitive we've seen in recent history
that if you don't finish the job then it
just comes back to haunt you and makes
things worse later so so he's right
about that
we're not actually disagreeing on ends
here but we're talking about means and
in fact in the doctrine of just war all
the way back to aquinas and hugo gracias
and all the other people in our
tradition have written about these
things there is this concept of
proportionality
if the aim is to defeat the enemy then
let's try and do it if you're going to
be as civilized and reflective about it
as you can be
even though war is a dirty business and
we've granted from marks i made earlier
on that there have to be limits even in
war then you've got to try and do it in
a way which is consistent with that idea
of proportion what i mean by it is this
if you have a toothache you can cure it
by chopping off your head but that's a
bit extreme you try and cure it by a
means that leaves the rest of you intact
if you can and so so something some you
know considered way of of doing these
things is obviously the preferred option
on the point about the so i'm drawing an
analogy here between the idea of an
annihilating defeat and using any means
available to you to get that defeat in
order to make sure that the monster
isn't going to rise up again and on that
we're absolutely agreed but what i want
to try to do is to discriminate in the
literal sense of that term is to look at
a central fact about something i ask
ourselves the question uh you've set
yourself a certain aim
is it a legitimate means to that end
to um pick
a civilian population
to attack it to kill as many of them as
you can to frighten everybody else by
that terrifying attack on them is that
ever justified now there might be
circumstances there might be very very
extreme circumstances where the great
and and sometimes worthwhile fig leaf of
the um
idea of collateral damage comes into
play here the idea that
there are very very regrettable
sincerely regrettable but unavoidable
casualties
of non-competence of innocence of people
who aren't engaged when a legitimate
target is attacked but i think one has
to be very careful about that one has to
say that has got to be the rare occasion
you've got to make a jolly good case for
claiming that it was unavoidable that
those people were hurt
and if you're doing something very
different from that if you're actually
targeting
civilians in order to kill and terrorize
that in itself the intrinsic quality of
that act no matter whether you think
you've got a declared war no matter
whether it's states that are the actors
in the case in other words a terrorist
organization
has to be wrong if you think 911 was
wrong and it was it was an atrocity then
you've got to think that systematically
and deliberately attempting to massacre
civilians in any circumstance is an
atrocity so i'm going to stick with that
point now i must pick up a hitch on the
on the um oh thank you though
so
the the the point about mutiny okay um i
i think uh with great respect hitch
misreads me that i didn't think that the
raf should mutiny i quote in the book
the uh um phrase in the vermacht
playbook which said that if you think
you've been given an illegal order you
can disobed
and that it actually happened that's uh
where marked soldiers i don't think very
many ss so just did but some exempted
themselves from actions that they didn't
agree with
and survived
um now in in the case of the the royal
air force personnel the usaf personnel i
say that in an ideal world i say preface
that don't i say in an ideal situation
if these
airmen were asked um will you go in for
area bombing bombing civilian
populations or will you go for uh
tactical targets important military
industrial targets that they should have
opted for the latter i didn't say they
should mutiny certainly not
and i grant also a number of things i
grant that they really believed with
with great justification that they were
engaged in a just war that they have the
support of the majority of their
populations these were young men putting
their lives on the line it moves me to
think that 55 000
very very young men died in the sky over
germany in the royal air force from from
britain and the british empire
45 000 united states army air force
personnel died in the air a terrifying
awful death
and i have to comment because it is one
of the awful ironies of war it's the
sort of thing that each would appreciate
maybe
that those 55 000 royal air force
personnel died
in the process of killing 350 000
germans
german children and women and elderly
people and people who were
not directly engaged in act of combat
a ratio of seven to one
what general would send his troops into
battle if he thought those were the odds
okay i think i've got you i mean unless
okay you could write me down uh ladies
and gentlemen if you like but
you haven't vetted me now well it isn't
preface actually it's i'm not quibbling
but you you phrase the question like
this
under hard questions should everyone
have refused to carry out area bombing
raids yes
then the there's then as you say your
reasoning follows but it's not you don't
preface it with that yes means yes it
seems to me um and i think
i would not have said it i mean
commander hitchens of blessed memory
i can promise you did not join the royal
navy and sail all around the world um
for his majesty the king in order to end
up
running guns to stalin which he ended up
doing over the hump of moments in
archangel uh when the scandinavian coast
was entirely controlled by the um
luftwaffe the seas largely controlled by
the u-birds very unpleasant job he
thought it was outrageous to be helping
the stalin regime to go but he did not i
think well this is so much against my
conscience i can't do it how could i
have impeached him if he had
well these might be questions for
another day i i think i'm glad on the
whole that people decided that the
british government was a decent enough
one to have its orders obeyed even if
questionable things were being done and
i could instance a whole number of other
episodes in the
second world war possibly the sinking of
the french fleet at anchor when it was
not in aggressive mode that british did
that were also to be uh questioned that
would make an excellent moral exercise
um let me stop you just for a second
because i want to make sure that there
is time okay but i have to say this
it's extending my point
precision bombing would have done an
awful lot of damage to the german war
effort in dresden there's no question
about it
and probably more arguably more than
area bombing did but the next day
precision bombing would have left the
same people in charge of dresden i'm
sorry to say and victor clamper would
have got on that
[ __ ] cattle truck
the same because the order wouldn't have
been destroyed there wouldn't have been
total chaos the the utter destruction of
the state system and it's uh
now
anyone who's seen the pictures of those
even in german camps camps on german
soil relatively lenient
i'm a book involved
the condition of the people who as they
were found
uh by vibration american soldiers can
see this people only got a few more days
to live at best
they're all dying in fact
another few months of this war and they
would all have died as so many of them
did in poland and hungary and elsewhere
this also has to be born in mining
considering the japanese empire and its
hideous god king
uh every day that that that country
didn't surrender i personally opposed to
hiroshima and nagasaki
i can tell you something that dr edward
teller once told me that it was his view
that there should have been a
demonstration bomb dropped and not the
use of it on civilian cities
but urgent questions let off upon
because every day the japanese empire
goes on
thousands of its slaves are dying and we
have the right and the duty to save them
it seems to me
so
um
i am sorry if that's not too much but i
i thought i could not say that this is
urgent
and it's a terrible utilitarian calculus
shall you kill more germans to rescue
their slaves and their victims well
you could i suppose the you can compose
it by saying
if i if i pray this is what i would say
i don't but
i would say well thank god we thank god
we didn't start this could i trespass
everybody's patience because there's a
point not not to disagree with it this
time but just a point to uh cognate what
he's just said there which is that on
the 28th of march 1945 churchill sent a
memo to manchester charles portal who
was the head of the raf uh to say to him
the terror bombing of the german cities
that's his phrase the terror bombing
must now stop
he said the uh the bombing of dresden is
a serious query against raf behavior
it's very interesting that he wrote this
this memo because at
certain points during the war he came
out tremendous speeches about you know
flattening with german cities and on
other occasions he had
horrible fits of of uh conscience about
it one occasion when he leapt to his
feet watching footage of bombing of the
rue valley which was a heavily
industrialized area of germany and said
are we animals what are we doing why are
we doing this this is right in the
middle of the war
and that memory that he sent the 28th of
march was returned to him by sir charles
portal with a note saying you can't
write to me like this and you're in
effect accusing me of a war crime you
can't say this about us you've got to
rewrite this in milder terms which
churchill did but the original memo was
kept on fire and was published by the
official historians of bomber command in
1960 webster and franklin both of whom
had had their very serious doubts about
the banning the bombing campaign
but what's interesting about it is this
at the end of march
churchill's anxieties which i suspect
had been fueled certainly by by anthony
eden but also by senior army officers
who were getting to and fro between uh
conquered parts of germany and back to
to london and they were saying my god
you ought to see what's what's happened
there and what you know what we've done
and all those anxieties and in fact he
mentioned um just that sort of reaction
uh on the part of of drybag
um but then within two weeks the first
of the concentration camps was liberated
by allied troops now in ghana uh
bergen-belsen
dachau
buchenwald
and the
footage the newsreel footage coming out
of germany showing british tommies and
bulldozers
moving huge piles of emaciated bodies
into mass graves that so horrified the
world quite rightly so
the whole world was so disgusted and
enraged by what we were seeing coming
out of germany that the debate
about the bombing was of course and i
think properly dwarfed by it it's one
reason why it's taken so long really for
for for people to be able to get enough
perspective to separate things out you
know like that game of pick up sticks
you get all the different separate them
out and just look at the that part of
the bombing campaign the area bombing
campaign just by itself and to examine
it in our own consciences about it
march 45 is a funny time for churchill
to develop scruples especially with what
i said about the final solution
and i believe i'm writing saying that
nowhere in any one of his histories any
one volume of this multi-volume history
the second world war is the final
solution mentioned
i had a feeling for rather larger
mission from churchill and
historiography i had a feeling i
wouldn't have to do a whole lot up here
to get the conversation going um so i'm
not i won't ask any questions but but i
open the floor up to anyone in the
audience um can we start right there um
and then we'll come down to the front
row right here
and then we'll go and then we'll go over
to this side right here so those will be
the first three and then we'll keep
going please mr hedges
yes
apart from the morality of it
do you think that terrorizing civilian
populations works
um
well i think this was liberating the
civilian population
i mean i don't we don't know how
terrorized people were we know that the
nazis kept a constant watch on people
who appeared to be celebrating or
fraternizing with advancing western
russian troops hang them from the
lampposts some of you may have seen the
extraordinary film uh
downfall
recently made in germany
downfall stanford the extraordinary
the regime kept on acting
pornographically till the very very end
and one sh can't overlook the
facts it's mentioned the word
terrorizing that hitler's intention was
not to terrorize the german people but
if possible to have them destroyed as
unworthy of national socialism he wanted
a holocaust if you like for the germans
uh that seems to me it can't be left out
of the moral account i don't believe we
were trying to terrorize the population
i think we're making it clear that the
hitler had brought them into a trap
from which there was no escape
and that that the revenge upon this this
maniac this monster
would be something that the world would
never ever ever forget
um i take the burden of your question to
be about the
whether or not the the bombing had the
effect really of of buckling morale and
it's a sort of an oddity in a way given
the fact that the morale of the british
people was uh um stiffened uh in fact as
well as in propaganda about by the
bombing um that the conductors of the
raf's bombing campaign are the harris in
particular i shouldn't have realized
that there might be a you know sort of
counterproductive effect
um
and it's it's really quite interesting
to see that that in fact happened in
germany it certainly played into joseph
goebbels hands because he was able to
use
the uh the area bombing campaign
as a as an argument to the german people
for resisting saying you know they're
acting in this barbaric way you can see
they've no hobart no hoes bar as far as
they're concerned they're going to do
anything to us so we've really got to
hang in there he was cheered in the
streets of berlin this is joseph
goebbels being cheered in the streets of
berlin and you know
berliner schnauzer and all the rest of
they weren't very happy about the nazis
nazis either
until
harris's so-called battle of berlin
which started in late 1943 went through
to the early spring of 1944 um
attempting to break the spirit of the
berliners and it did anything but
so um your question is
is a very interesting one the hope that
it would
force the the german population to turn
on its government and tell them to sue
for peace was uh was an empty one
next question is here can i just suggest
that that you'd address questions to
both of them and and i'm sure both of
them will pick up on them
this is particularly to professor
grayling
with regard to um
the question of hiroshima and nakasaka
namely
no the argument one hears
which is i find at least partially
persuasive is that
these uh use of atomic bombs
could be justified in reducing the
casualties for in
in the war against japan because
they
uh shortened the war i mean it certainly
seems clear they did shorten the war the
u.s was was be getting prepared for a
mass invasion with and anticipating you
know perhaps a hundred thousand
casualties and who money who knows how
many japanese casualties so
what would you say about the calcu the
moral calculus in that decision
obviously
you know altogether maybe a hundred
thousand were killed in the two bombings
but
is that still dying too
i still died still dying yeah but
just
i mean can when
make the case that that
uh preempted you know maybe half a
million being killed
well i would in order to accept that
point we'd have to accept the premise
that uh the japanese weren't ready to
make peace on the morning of the 6th of
august before the first bomb went off
and that now
there's a very very wide consensus now
that's just not the case but for months
beforehand they've been making overtures
for discussions about peace and that
there were other
motives on the american side for not
agreeing to talks they wanted i mean
there seems to be a counter argument to
the point about saving lives to keep the
war going until the bombs were ready you
ask yourself the question why did they
drop two bombs i mean one might have
been enough well the answer is they were
two different kinds of bombs
they've kept cities relatively unbombed
in order to see what the effect would be
turn down the idea of doing a
demonstration and also for months
beforehand you know solitary b-29s were
sent over japanese cities very very high
up 30 000 feet five thousand feet to
drone around a little bit over the city
and then go away again so that the
japanese population would get used to
having these solitary what they thought
reconnaissance aircraft overhead in fact
the japanese called the mrb
it's a harmless bombers that came
overhead and then went away so that on
the morning of the 6th of august and
there was a solitary droning b-29 above
hiroshima nobody took any nations nobody
was in an airway shelter or anything
else when that bomb went off and there
is a chilling description by by hersh i
think talking about seeing a line of
soldiers with their hands on the
shoulder of the soldier in front
all blind because they'd all been
looking up at the bomber when the flash
happened and their eyes were turned
to liquid and ran down their cheeks like
tears christian see your point um would
be met by a demonstration bomb of the
kind that the famous doctor i would tell
her told me he would he had favored the
same effect could have been produced on
the 5th of august or earlier
um if other things being equal the only
reason i can think and i've never heard
a justification for nagasaki as a matter
of fact
um is this because the the argument that
it shortened the war was never made in
1945
in any cabinet discussion we have all
the papers now nobody said let's do it
to shorten the war
some appear to have said let's do it to
impress joseph stalin which hey it's the
reason we've destroyed dresden already
stalin seems to require a lot of
immolated cities for his
self-satisfaction um
the the other is possibly to uh
deter the soviet union um advancing into
japanese islands
but i think not until 1948 does anyone
come up with the excuse well it
shortened the war so all of you who are
out of the pacific theater should be
grateful you've got home early it's it's
a bogus argument unfortunately um
the only the other thing one could say
is well it's it's completely
annihilating there's going to be no one
in the japanese office at all after the
surrender saying ah but
perhaps you know we could have a
comeback one day
the
the impossible rise again they know they
know that's it you really have lost this
time again this is an argument that i
find myself very uncomfortable
even rehearsing because i'll quantify
will and possibly wicked but
these are psychological effects we take
for granted that we didn't have in our
arsenal at the time
finally
not in the arsenal of the raf or usaf
were rocket bombs
v1s and v2s which started falling on
london to a considerable extent
in 1945 and in fact it's universally
agreed the british morale at that point
was likely to crack because people
thought it was nearly over and they
couldn't stand they thought it was
starting again and this time not bombers
that could be shot down but rocket bombs
exploding without warning
you read steven spender's diaries of
being a fireman in london at that point
and elsewhere all that stuff about
british pluck and so on i mean i'm
wedded to it okay and believe me
but it's very very overdone the people
were really really flaking
now at that point you say well what else
look we know the nazis are trying for
horror weapons what's on the next damn
rocket
what do we know is coming
maybe it'll be gas
maybe it'll be germs we don't know what
we do know is we're going to flatten
anywhere which can launch one of those
those damn rockets
and we're entitled to anything
that's how people are going to think if
they're fought in this way this was
germany
not germany but hitler
urging suicide on his people
let me add a couple of things to what
hits you just said there um maybe right
this point about the shortening the war
thing was the post factory justification
it did happen though that truman wrote a
letter on the ninth of august the day of
the second bomb in which he said uh um
we will take all measures necessary to
you know reduce the number of our own
military casualties so that that point
was put that early in a letter which in
other respects is full of weasel
expressions like i'm doing my utmost to
ensure that there are no you know we
minimize civilian casualties and so on
this was written on the 9th of august so
so there is that point um which is right
you know the the the germans didn't
build big bombers what they did was they
concentrated their efforts on building
guided missiles it was terror adorno one
of the
one of the pluses on our side in this
exchange absolutely who said um
you can tell that the human race has got
cleverer over time but not wiser because
of the development from the spear into
the guided missile well the first guided
missile was was fired off in the summer
of 1944 was kept in reserve for when the
invasion happened and then there was
this summer campaign summer and into the
early autumn of 1944 that the v1s and
v2s were coming over and causing
devastation in in london particularly
and one or two other places
the v1 the doodlebug you could hear it
and then when the engine cut out you
knew it was going to form everybody held
their breaths but the v2 you couldn't
hear you didn't know it was coming until
it exploded and the old lady lives
across the road for me and i talk in my
book about the bomb site across the
heroid from my house and right next to
it is a lady now in her late 80s who was
in that house one day when a v1 fell a
v2 rather fell a couple of blocks away
and she tells this story about how she
was standing at the window
at the kitchen sink looking through the
window and her little son was playing on
the lawn outside and this terrific
explosion went off as you realize it was
a v2 so she ran out to
see if her son was okay and he was
absolutely fine but she wasn't because
the window had been blown in she was
streaming blood and her little son was
traumatized by the vision of this woman
streaming blood screaming at him and
running like this with her arms held
wide so you can just imagine how
absolutely awful it is but the v
attack had peated out more or less by
the autumn of 1944 partly because it was
interdicted there were attacks on the
launch sites but also because the just
the number that the germans had of them
wasn't very great and it's an
interesting fact that in the autumn of
1944 arthur harris got back command of
bomber command it had been under
eisenhower's uh charge since before the
d-day uh landings and had done a
fantastic job which harris always
claimed he could never do of tactical
bombing of
supplies and the german army and france
and rail heads and bridges and so on and
he got it back and between the autumn of
1944 and the 25th of april 1945 when the
bombing campaign was stood down
arthur harris dropped more bombs on
germany than in the whole of the war
beforehand and he had a list of cities
and they included gems like fort simon
hildesheim and wurzburg and others that
were bombed than the people who lived in
them just could not understand why
because he could
because he could that's exactly the
point yeah the next question is this
gentleman here in the white shirt and
then we're going to go up to the back
for a question after that
i'd like to make two brief factual
points first one both of you mentioned
that hamburg was the center of the
german working class the implication
being that a lot of good people died in
the fire bombing of hamburg i think it's
worth mentioning this connection that
hamburg also was the home of police
battalion 101 which is described by
christopher browning in this herring
description of how the mass killing of
jews took place the killing of women
children
by mass shootings thousands of
of victims being shot by these good
people from hamburg every day now the
second point is more important uh
according to the man in charge of german
war production spare
uh there was a degrading effect as a
result of the
area bombing of german cities and spare
gives
figures that so many more planes could
have been produced and so many more
tanks could have been produced and so
forth
i'm not prepared to argue that this is
decisive that this is a matter of and
justifying means and so forth
but i think it should become part of the
moral calculus and therefore it is wrong
simply to say
the
area bombing was
no utility at all possibly was even
counterproductive and so forth the facts
are it had some effect and that should
be taken into account
anthony um on that second point i i
think as
you know when spear was imprisoned in
prison before the the nuremberg trials
he was invited by um
an allied commission to come and talk to
them about production during the war and
he astonished them
by saying that until the end of 1944
production was on the up
he made the point to an audience that
wanted to hear it that um it wouldn't it
wasn't rising as fast as he would have
liked yes that takes account of that
point but the fact of the matter is that
it was rising he complained that hitler
never allowed him to put the economy on
a total war footing because hitler had
this anxiety about what had happened in
1919 when the german economy couldn't
provide cigarettes and flower pots and
things like that to the german
people who were annoyed about it because
lots of shortages occur because of this
transfer of productive capacity to other
ends and so he never allowed it and it
turned out never to be necessary anyway
because of the enormous resources that
were available and it was the bottleneck
things the oil the the coal uh that the
transport that uh in the end scuppered
it and it was in january 1945 that
shabir wrote hitler and said the war is
over from the production point of view
because i just now can't get the
resources together to do it i'm in in
the book by the way i quote uh how the
germans dealt with with bombing damage i
talk in particular about the thousand
bomber raid on cologne in 1942 and how
many millions of cigarettes and sheets
and pints of milk and loaves of bread
were on the autobahns going into cologne
within days of the of the bombing rate
how short of time it took to re-house
people partly because the germans knew
that since they were going to start the
war they made preparations for it very
early beginning 1935-36
but also because they had these massive
manpower resources that never affected
their their military capacity on the day
that the war ended in europe the day
that berlin fell there were 10 million
men of military age in the wehrmacht
between the ages of 18 and 35 all with
boots on and all with guns in their
hands
but you do say
it's important i bet you've personally
regarded alberta as a
pathological liar
and he was always trying to please
different audiences but he did say after
the bombing of hamburg he said another
half dozen such raids would [ __ ]
germany's war production that's what he
thought then but this subjective he
later discovers that's not true so he
could have been panicked it might have
been worth trying to stampede a few
other people
a mention of these uh staunch fellows in
their chat boots though it compels me to
say again shapiro's empire of production
which included i think i'm writing
saying the factories that built the
rocket weapons and other places was a
slave empire these were not germans
working
they were slaves from russia and poland
and yugoslavia and greece and elsewhere
i'm in favor of the liberation of slaves
okay whatever it takes
and i think you may it can be something
you have to undertake in a hurry you're
certainly morally obliged to undertake
it
and those whose manpower and well-being
all the cigarettes you can get so depend
upon slavery have made a pact which
they'll upon which they may be called to
witness
sorry to sound like a preacher but their
their their bloody well is and those
slaves were liberated before they could
be exterminated or before they could be
worked to death and i think this really
must be part of
what you call the calculus sir
so i'm alerted by if i may i'm terribly
sorry alerted by a phrase we're dying of
politeness
[Laughter]
whatever it takes that phrase that it's
uses there uh you know we agree means
necessary as the traditional slogan yeah
by any means by any means necessary um
and also by any means effective i've got
to say because um somebody sent me an
email shortly after my book came out in
the uk a professor of economics and
andrews university and he said to me uh
i find your book incredibly interesting
i'd just like to let you know that uh
you know there's quite a bit of
discussion about um what would have
happened if the whole bombing effort of
the royal air force and the united
states army air force had been focused
on industrial and military targets if
the raf had really backed up the united
states army air force on this one he
said the war could have been two years
shorter if they'd done that that's a
fantastic thought if if correct you know
but of course it's supposed to surmise
about it but it suggests something which
is that the area bombing the attacks on
the civilian populations were not part
of what was necessary they were not
necessary to winning the war and that in
a way if it's you know if any sense
attaches to the idea of potentiating the
degree of of moral criminality of an act
it just makes things worse that they
weren't it wasn't really having any
that it was marginal and yet it caused
this huge number of casualties
i want to go up in the back um way up in
the back on the left uh in fact we
scuppered a gentleman here because i i i
interrupted i'm so sorry this gentleman
here with the beard well we'll come
we'll come right back we'll come back to
him next but go up go up there yeah
uh yes the veterans history project of
the library congress houses uh a
somewhat incredible collection of at
this point 40 000 oral histories
and more than half of those are world
war ii veterans
and i have yet to
hear a testimony or read
a letter or a manuscript
that has any compunction
about the dropping of the atomic bomb
to a man every veteran sees this as
bringing a war to an end and i think it
is quite interesting to seem to have
discounted that from all of our
discussions it's one thing to look at
the documents and to look at the leaders
it's quite another thing to look at the
opinions of the men who are expected to
put their lives on the line and to
actually execute that war
okay but it's not unlike the huge
population explosion of jews in france
in during the second world war
i mean i mean by that to say
i'm sure you've had the same experience
ever been to a french farmhouse that
didn't shelter at least six jews
i have not
there must have been a gigantic growth
of jewish population undefeated it seems
to me likewise i hate to say this i have
never met
an american serviceman who is anywhere
near the pacific theater who has not
told me
that on the 7th of august 1945 his
regiment was scheduled to go
into the home islands of japan they all
seem to believe it
now i wasn't there and i i'm not one to
want to quarrel with
um the guys in uniform but it can't be
true
and the argument was not made to them at
the time hey we've shortened the war you
can go home this is why we've done it
was not made so 1947
where at i believe it was very useful as
was the opening of bookend valve in
dakao
and nyongama instilling any conscience
that people might have had about what
they'd done ah well then now i see
why it was necessary
i think it's um i think one has to
distrust this stuff
very much in other words can i tell you
that just before i came across the pond
um i on the same day received a
telephone call
message on my answer phone and a letter
and the telephone call was from an
elderly gentleman who said
i'm phoning to say i've just finished
your book
i was an air crewman i was a sergeant
navigator in world air force bomber
command
and ever since the war i've
i've suffered in silence
the sense of terrible guilt of what we
did i felt it then i felt it ever since
i've never really been able to
articulate it and here it is being
articulated and i'm just phoning to
thank you and i mean to get a message
like that when you've written a book is
it's very moving
and i i've brushed the tear from my eye
and i opened the letter that was lying
on my desk and it said you bastard how
do you say this about how brave mary did
this
that wasn't the only letter i got but uh
there are always two sides to the story
and sometimes i
and then i think to myself why is it
that um that the person who wrote the
letter
who was angry with me for having written
the book uh and who's all therefore ever
since the war the woman in question was
an 82 year old ex-woman's auxiliary air
force um officer in fact she had seen
the pains going off and some of them not
coming back and that's one reason why
she was so angry because she saw she
witnessed the the you know
the sacrifice from from the british side
of the story um
why she never had to say anything
was never called upon to justify what
she was part of or or what had happened
because there was a consensus about it
whereas he felt
we'd won a victory with defeated a
terrible enemy who had to be defeated i
was part of that but at the same time
you know you read those accounts of
airmen who could feel the heat from
hamburg and from berlin and dresden in
their aircraft from 20 000 feet and see
the glow from hundreds of miles away as
they flew back again afterwards who
never said anything because they felt
that to do it would be some kind of
betrayal even of themselves and that's
one reason for silence
anyway we have group captain leonard
cheshire and many many other veterans
who took a different view even at the
time as well since so
um it's not in fact a perfect
correlation between being a combatant
and being a
an enthusiastic supporter of um area
bombing we're coming up on nine o'clock
um and uh and and i want to give time
for people to you know either buy books
outside and talk so um uh let me take
two more questions and and ask that they
be brief and ask that the responses be
brief but you will have a chance to talk
to each of them afterwards so if we
don't get to your question if you have a
receipt yeah
that doesn't matter well done
um here and here
yes yeah okay right sorry
thanks a lot you made a compelling uh
contextual arguments against the bombing
tactic um and i wanted to play devil's
advocate real quick if germany and japan
had come across a similar capacity to do
civilian bombings to the us and the uk
wouldn't be a handicap to not be able to
use the same tactic against germany and
japan prior to them actually doing it to
the us and the uk so if
your opponent can sucker punch you
wouldn't it be wrong to not be able to
or punch them before they did it to you
well i i think it the there's something
that lies behind the question that i
that i have to take issue with which is
that um uh
if the point in question were trying to
preempt their capacity to do that to you
to do an arrow bombing campaign against
you that the right thing to do would be
to
attack that capacity to attack their
aircraft and airfields and bomb-making
factories and so on but to attack their
civilians in their cities would have
been entirely the wrong strategy because
it would have left that affected their
ability to do it to you so
so that's my response
e.m foster wrote a great essay it's
reprinted in two cheers for democracy it
was actually delivered as a bbc
broadcast
in the early days of the struggle saying
um
he was very anti-militarist but he said
before we consider what germany might do
to us we should consider what is already
done to germany
the wreckage of german culture the the
smashing of the universities
the immigration of the genius germany
not not by any means all the jewish but
a lot of it which very probably meant
that they hugely [ __ ] their
ability to use physics for warfare
but we knew that they were working on it
and it's the only reason that men like
einstein would never have dreamt of
prostituting his talent in this way
and meals were willing to work on it too
was because of the dread that they might
get it first well now if you're in a
situation where you don't know
you know you know heisenberg is still in
germany you you know he's a great
physicist you don't know how much
resources he has
well you may you you have to consider
yourself entitled to try anything it
seems to me
it would be irresponsible be impeachable
not to do so
we don't know how close they came not
very they were defeated products they
were fascists
fascism is irrational and
self-destructive we can be grateful for
that like bin ladenism
sir uh the problem i'm having with the
moral position on this is that when you
take the moral position it's very
difficult to
attack it with logic
when one deals with it's regrettable
because
it's regarded because we were enraged
it's regrettable because we wanted to
send a message of revenge
it's regrettable because we wanted to
make stalin think twice
it's a very utilitarian argument
it seems to me to posit the moral
position
which is
you know either with it or you're not
is that the deliberate targeting of
civilians
whether from the air or from the ground
or for torture
or
holding them incommunicado for years or
whatever
suspension of habeas corpus and all of
these things
can be done for utilitarian reasons but
it seems to me
that when you take those positions and
you use them you are sailing from the
shores of civilization
and there's no return
that uh it's very hard then to draw
those lines
so you can't think of any circumstances
in which pacifism would be an immoral
position
well in fact i can but when i do that
i realize that i am creating a hole in
in a wall i'm breaching the logic i'm
taking a position that may in fact be
immoral
for some other reason that i believe it
overrides
the
fair
situation
anthony do you want it oh i just make a
tangential point uh
which is that the point of raising the
moral
issue at all even if it's post facto and
even if it's a long time afterwards
seems to me to
actually pack much more of a punch than
people realize i mean i wonder whether
it isn't the case that some military
commander somewhere or much more to the
point some politician making a decision
about going to war or doing something
during the course of a war
doesn't reflect what will happen in 30
or 40 years time when some meddling
philosopher comes along and says what he
did was bad you know and ruins his
reputation and that might be it probably
isn't it might be a constraint on some
people sometimes and you know the hope
the struggle is you know here we all are
we're in the in the raging seas of uh
controversy and history and we're trying
to hold the candle the lighted candle up
as high as possible and and that's the
point you know having the debate at all
is one way of trying to save something
back from uh our uh great endeavor to be
civilized and even in times of emergency
and having it at the time in london in
the press in parliament in the churches
and that's not terrible
it would be nice if the germans were
able to read that discussion would be
very nice they ought to have it
themselves
alas
wasn't the nature of the enemy that we
were confronting
you have been a terrific audience um
thank you for your patience um i trust
those positions well
if
i trust that's because you found it
interesting and thought-provoking and
and and uh and engaging which i
certainly did as well um thank you all
for coming um both anthony and
christopher will be outside afterwards
if you'd like to speak to them further
and appreciate your being here
ac grayling is a philosophy professor at
burbeck college university of london and
a fellow at the world economic forum his
book is among the dead cities
for more information visit his website
acgrayling.com